TALKABONIAL MEDIA.STOP HAVG  A
TS BILL ITHY WAS
SISTERS, THEY REFUTOEVEN DEBATE.
BI I
THAT'S WHAS UNFORGIVABLE AN'T
SOMETHING AS FUNMENTAL AS
VOTIY
IT T FAIR ARCAUSE THEY DAVA STRG
ZERO VOTEDOR L
RELIEF PACCH TO YOU ABOUT AT
AM HAVE  MAD
E ACT PEOPLE.
ZERO.
THEY DON'T WANT TOE
THEY DON'T WANT TO CHANGE UST W.
TAN ALSO E  FOR ANY PH
JOE MANCHINYERCRAT GETAG VOTES M
E FO
EITHER, TO GET TO0.
T' J.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, BROEROOD TO SEO
BROTHER.
>> THIS, THE BATTLE
HAS JUST BEGUN, SAYS,
WHY DO YOU THINKHED VOTEFOR ANYI
K ABT
HEOU AIVHO HAVE FO
OFESE BILLND DIED TO TST
DONORS, THEY HAVE DO
EVERYTHING THEY
>> IT'T
>> IT'S NOG SOY GOT
NOTH
ON THIS FULL COURT
THOUGH YOUW ANEVY
ELW THEY WOULD INTO
BATTLEFIELD, WE DID ALE DON'T WI
CONLEVEL.FET
GOING TO HELP NOW.
AT THELEVEL, WE ARE NOON.
WE HAVE TO COMD WE CANO
EVET FOR ONEF
ST
UP THET HILLTHE
MOIN A
R FW          OR, AND
TH'S T
I UNDERSND
AD
HIT TH WALL.T WE KNE
NOT TO LET THEM GHT AND DIE Y E.
OVER.
>> YEAH.
I TRY TO CALL THIS FAIR.
I K WE HAVE TO KEEP THE
PRESSURE ON.
DOHE SS
CORRECT,HE OYIIT, SO CTIHES TH
AN-RO VOTE.P THAT FIGHT UP.
DEO , RD, TRYINGT HOW TO
S UG
ES.
WE HAVE TO GET READY FOR THAT
MOTION,  OT MORE TIME ON THIS,
L T HAVE 10
THEY WON'T EVELET US TALK  WAY,
LE WHO FOUGHT THIS
OUT AND N.GETHER I
BLICAN
N'DEMOCRATS. REPUBLICANS WROTE Y
THS, AND WE TOOKHOSE
IS
WHEN WE, AND BLACK HE LDE W
GOING TO SAYN TEE RULES, WE'LL
PLAY BY THE RULES AND TH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN'T HELP
YOU.
THAT'S WHY PEO
ABOU,
LET US GET DOWN AND
LEGISLATIVELY AND THEY DID
NOTHING.
A LOT RE MAD AT SUMEER WH WH H
DON'T SAY ATRE INSULTING
McCONNELL.
THE ARGUMENT HE MADE TODAYCONNEH
NO  -- NO
YEARS.SS -PRTITS?HAVEN'T HEARD R
LOOK, I WISHOM
HE WE'RE GOINGTO KD WE'LENTUALL.
THISNGAT THEED
LEVE TCATELL
WE'VGOT TO R TO
REGISTER LIKE
REGISTERED BEFORE.
PART.L I
I DO THINK, D
Y WAS A BI OFOR YOUR
BUYER FO
HEAVE THEM A SHOY
DN'T DES TE STAKRE H
THN SAYING, AHA F R NTROL.
I THINK THAT'S S.JOIT TOGETR.
AN
>> HAN ORGANIZER, SO I GET
IT.
E'S SAYING I CAN'T LOOKO
OWNKNOW YOUED